all right it's a big day today because
it is time for the first hatred mail of
2018 here's a quick reminder about what
hatred mail is because we cling to our
guns and our God but somehow totally
cool with a billionaire who wants to
assault our wife Patriot man right
ridden by Patriots who hate David Pakman
because America and because freedom
alright so as a quick explainer because
it is we're resetting hatred mail and
twentieth year a beginning of the year
patriot mail is we take the crazy hate
mail that we receive and then a
professional voice-over artist narrates
it and does a dramatic reading of it and
we are starting the year off very very
strong take a listen to this week's
atria mail people just don't like you
Davey lisping homosexual communist puke
immigrant Jew boy pile of feces get back
to Community College with your little
boy friends and do your stupid little
America hating propaganda show their
maybe at Community College you can get
some help with your gay little Lisp Kirk
why is immigrant in quotes we put up a
transcript of this for people and every
single insult was there in the literal
sense but immigrant was in quotes I
really was born in Argentina and came to
the United States as a kid I don't know
why you would put that in quotes almost
like Donald Trump dictated this yeah
it's actually that is the quotes and
capital letter Z the only thing that's
missing is the capital letters and weird
parenthetical phrases and and and
whatnot this is a very very strong
hatred mail to start the year on I feel
yeah I mean I made a new year's
resolution that I'm not gonna let hatred
mail get to me I'm not gonna lose sleep
over it right and I hope you do the same
I've been doing it for years absolutely
and I'm gonna continue that in 2018 you
can turn hatred mail into something
positive we have a membership coupon
code which is hey tree at 40
that's H 80 RI o T 4-0 and if you go to
david pakman.com slash membership pick
any membership you like and put in the
coupon code hey tree at 40 when you're
checking out you will save 40% off of
your membership it is the way to sort of
give a middle finger to the hatred
it's when you use that coupon code